it's tough to know how we might respond
to a true disaster what might any of us
do when the world turns upside down and
nothing makes sense anymore what if the
simple act of stepping outside into the
sunlight became the deadliest thing in
the world we've delved into this
horrifying notion before with
scp-001 when daybreaks or sd lock's
proposal one of the most nightmarish xk
class end-of-the-world scenarios ever
devised mr rogers once said that the
best thing to do in times of trouble is
look to the helpers no matter how dire
things become there will always be those
taking up the difficult work of putting
their community back together
firefighters emergency medical services
soup kitchens there are so many
different kinds of helpers out there
unfortunately most of them would be the
first to go once the sun's rays turned
on us all the firefighter attempting to
put out a blaze would melt into a puddle
of goo the emt running out of an
ambulance would melt the second his feet
hit the pavement when doom and
destruction are everywhere who is left
to help perhaps someone who has always
dreamed of saving humanity from a great
plague but is trapped inside with no
sunlight in sight when the whole world
has grown sick humanity forever changed
into something terrible we just might
need a doctor today we're looking at
what happens when a dedicated physician
meets his greatest challenge yet we've
discussed scp-049 many times before he's
a humanoid entity standing roughly 1.9
meters in height resembling a man
dressed in the garb of a medieval plague
doctor he is clad in thick dark robes
and a ceramic mask that tapers into a
long sharp beak though it may look like
a costume these adornments are actually
part of the entity's body
scp-049 wants one thing to cure
humankind of a mysterious pestilence the
nature of which has never been entirely
clear sadly his work tends to do more
harm than good he can kill with a single
touch and his attempts to cure human
subjects result in malformed zombies
instead he carries around a black
doctor's bag capable of holding an
impossible amount of medical implements
which he uses to perform his work though
his actions tend to result in more harm
than good the plague doctor seems to
genuinely care about his patients their
well-being and curing them of the
illness he believes to be ravaging their
bodies
scp-049 is singular in his obsession
with eradicating the plague he so often
speaks of and he will not stop until he
has done so but what does a doctor do
when there are no more patients left to
treat when humanity has been wiped out
and the pestilence is gone for good
let's peek in on the doctor in his
containment cell and see what he's up to
it appears that he's working on
something or perhaps it's better to say
someone but what is this new creation it
looks too small to be a human too
human-like to be an animal it looks too
much
like him has it finally happened has the
plank doctor begun to reproduce himself
it seems the answer is yes but not in
the way you might think since it appears
what he has created is a plush version
of everyone's favorite masked malady man
that's right the plague doctor has
created something special and now for
the first time you can have a plague
doctor of your very own by going to
scp-swag.com and ordering one right now
and with this one you don't have to
worry about waking up to find that
you've been converted into a walking
zombie-like shell of your former self no
this nearly 10 inch tall plush which
comes complete with his own removable
doctor's bag is a soft squeezable
version of the scp-049 that we all know
and love or fear put him on your shelf
carry him with you in your own bag or
set him on your desk so that you always
have someone to discuss your own
theories of what exactly the pestilence
is we just can't promise that he'll
divulge any secrets since this little
plague doctor seems especially
tight-lipped we know you'll love him as
much as we do though so go to
scp-swag.com and order one for yourself
right now supplies are limited so don't
wait but back to the taller and more
mobile plague doctor the doctor sat in
his containment cell as he did every
other day of his captivity doing his
best to keep busy the scientists of the
scp foundation were small-minded they
did not comprehend the gravity of his
work the necessity of ridding the world
of the pestilence he forgave them for
their ignorance for they did not know
what they were doing instead he kept his
mind on the goal the duty he had as a
physician and a man of the sciences just
as many scientists had done in the past
when their work was unappreciated
copernicus was persecuted for his model
of the universe and his knowledge that
the earth revolved around the sun jonas
for his controversial invention of the
polio vaccine that saved countless lives
scp-049 would be remembered fondly by
history for his contributions even if
his contemporaries did not understand
his vision and so in spite of the
suspicion and doubt that surrounded him
at this foundation that should have been
all for groundbreaking research the
doctor carried on with his work he sat
on the floor of the cell his bag opened
next to him from its endless interior he
withdrew syringes bottles of viscous
liquids tissue samples suspended in jars
and a stainless steel table upon which
he could place it all today he would
perform a new round of tests on samples
he had been able to extract from
previous patients before he was thrown
into this unjust imprisonment these
doctors men he had once viewed as
colleagues had not brought him a new
test subject in quite some time a guard
had muttered something about it being
too costly to keep wasting perfectly
good cows on him simpletons fools
luddites beating their fists against
their own chests in the face of true
progress their small minds were of no
concern to him the doctor placed his
tools on his work table and began to
take out the samples an ear a piece of
skin taken from the bottom of a foot a
section of a liver and most exciting of
all the frontal lobe of a human brain
indeed it would be a fruitful day of
investigation into the mysteries of the
great dying he was just pulling a
scalpel from his bag when his
concentration was suddenly interrupted
by the sound of a blaring siren he set
his tools down and looked up that sound
it signified trouble at the facility but
surely it would be over soon once the
issue had been dealt with outside his
cell he could hear the thundering
footsteps of guards running past
shouting at one another too quickly for
him to understand one man stepped over
to peer into 049 cell making sure he was
still contained most likely my good
fellow the doctor called out reminding
himself to speak in the king's english
so the man could understand would you be
so kind as to enlighten me what is the
trouble if anyone has been injured i
would be happy to offer my assistance
the man did not respond his attention
grabbed by something further down the
hall that the doctor could not see wait
he cried but the guard had already
disappeared the siren continued to blare
assaulting his senses with its shrill
tone in the distance he could hear
screams surely there was a dire
situation at hand had that damnable
reptile escaped again he approached the
door to his cell listening for further
information there was no roaring no
sounds of walls crumbling there was only
that blasted alarm and the screams of
unadulterated fear and agony very
curious and quite troubling
scp-049 tried to open the door knowing
that it was futile he had never been
able to escape before why would that
change now still a scientist must repeat
his efforts in order to gather new data
so he thrust his shoulder against the
door attempting to break it down it did
not budge instead an automatic
containment measure was triggered
releasing lavender scented gas into the
room in an attempt to calm the doctor
down he did love the scent it reminded
him of gentler times long ago he took a
deep breath imagining fields of purple
flowers swaying in the summer breeze
that was the world he fought for not the
flawed human beings that opposed him not
this sterile facility packed with the
ignorant for now he would return to the
work if they did not desire his help
there was nothing more to be done
sometime later perhaps hours perhaps
days he could not be certain when there
was no sunlight to gauge the time by the
alarm fell silent the doctor stopped his
ministrations and listened as the alarm
had stopped so too had the screams in
fact the whole facility seemed to have
gone completely eerily silent hello he
called out but there was no response
save for a clicking sound now that was a
sound he had heard before normally it
signified the arrival of armed guards
who would strap him into a harness knock
him out and take him somewhere else it
was the sound of the door to his
containment cell unlocking but there was
no one there could it be grabbing his
faithful bag as cp049 cautiously pushed
against the door it swung open revealing
a darkened vacant hallway gone were the
harsh fluorescent lights the d-class
personnel mopping blood stains off the
floors the doctors hurrying by with
clipboards in hand everyone was gone
from what he could see at least he would
have to investigate further in order to
know for sure a scientist never assumes
until they have all of the available
information after all so scp-049 walked
the halls of the seemingly abandoned
foundation site expecting to be
interrupted at any moment by an
adversary in a white coat who would
usher him back to his prison but the
interruption never came as he rounded
the corner past one of the containment
facilities a familiar voice called out
to him excuse me please could you help
me open the door zero four nine stopped
and peered into the room it was the
possessive masks room
scp-035
the doctor opened the door and there it
was the porcelain mask grinning at him
from its glass case
thick black liquid oozed from its eyes
and wide open mouth oh wonderful it's
you the mask gleefully enthused my good
man you gentlemen and scholar would you
please release me from this awful case
049 paused considering the potential
ramifications of this action no doubt
you've noticed that things have changed
around here the mass continued the
foundation is
different now the old rules have gone
out the window hmm so it would seem the
doctor replied i will not wear you
understood i will only release you from
your cage and for that i will be
eternally grateful the mask promised the
doctor approached the glass case in
several quick strides and with one
gloved fist broke through the glass
thank you old friend the mask cried out
now take me with you the doctor shook
his head i have more pressing matters to
attend to at the moment if it is true
if they have all gone then this facility
is in dire need of a new head researcher
at his words the mask's visage changed
the cheerful smile warping into an
exaggerated frown and you think you're
the man for the job how embarrassing how
truly tragic bite your tongue the doctor
retorted ah but i don't have one some
physician you are the mask taunted
unwilling to deal with the porcelain
fiends naysaying any longer the doctor
turned and swept out of the room now was
not the time for such verbal sparring he
had so much to do this whole facility
could be his new workshop his laboratory
and he would need assistance to help him
manage it but who was qualified enough
loyal to the cause armed with sharp wit
and a body free of pestilence as he made
his way through the pitch black halls he
felt something nudge his leg he glanced
down uncertain what he would find and
saw a tear-drop shaped orange creature
nudging him affectionately gazing up at
him with one large unblinking eye next
to his other leg a mustard yellow
creature the same shape and size was
rolling toward him are you friend the
foe the doctor asked the creatures
continued to nudge against his legs
seeming to want something attention
perhaps he bent down and patted each
creature gently they rolled around his
feet in circles making a delighted
babbling sound ah companion it is well
then come along as he continued his path
the little creatures rolled after him
keeping close to his heels suddenly they
began to babble loudly in a panicked
tone swarming around the front of his
feet as if to stop him is there a danger
here my ocular friends the doctor asked
from the cell up ahead a voice cried out
in french help please i'm so hungry the
doctor rushed to the door opening it to
reveal a behemoth of a man with a large
rounded chin and jaw and deep-set eyes
that peered down at him the man grinned
at the doctor with impossibly large
teeth thank you sir i was sure i would
die in there as he stepped out into the
light the doctor could see this giant
was dressed in a military uniform are
you a military man the doctor asked yes
i was a soldier in the french army once
the giant replied before i became the
greatest detectives the world has ever
known the doctor clapped his hands
delightedly his eyes glittering from
within his mask intelligence and loyalty
not to mention strength you my good man
are everything i have been searching for
would you do me the honor of working as
my assistant i have a great deal of
research to do and could make use of a
man with your many talents the giant
tipped his hat politely to the doctor it
would be my honor sir you may call me
fernand he reached out for a handshake
but the doctor shook his head it would
be best if i did not but it is a
pleasure to make your acquaintance he
glanced down at the ipods still
scattering about anxiously see there is
nothing to fear here unless i don't find
something to eat soon for an end quipped
and so the doctor continued on his way
with fernan and his new pets in tow this
was an excellent advancement but he
would need a great deal more help if he
was to effectively run the foundation he
recruited two other anomalies with a
mind for scientific research a small
bird with a deafening voice and a doctor
himself and an eloquent sea slug with
years of hunting and adventuring
experience it was a relief to find
fellow intellectuals here as the
ever-increasing band of anomalies
approached the basement fernand peaked
up noticeably something smells wonderful
just beyond this door fernand opened the
door and led the group into a treasure
trove of corpses they had found the
foundation's morgue rows and rows of
drawers filled with test subjects and
food for ferdinand it was everything the
doctor could have possibly wanted my
dear ferdinand take as many as you can
carry and follow me to the laboratory
the doctor declared tallyho
cried the slug [__] and how dr spenco
added the doctor set up shop in one of
the many expansive on-site labs though
the electricity was out he could still
get a great deal of use out of it there
was so much space in here so many more
resources than his tiny cell had within
a matter of hours he had set up rows of
ivs pumping out his serums into test
subjects reanimating them into more lab
assistants the newly revived corpses
shambled around the lab bringing him
bone saws and forceps vials and needles
of all sizes as the doctor worked harder
than he had in years the others were
less help than he had hoped but with so
many newly treated patients to share the
workload he hardly noticed all of these
poor souls victims of the pestilence no
doubt and he had all the time in the
world now to cure them before long the
once vacant halls of the foundation were
filled with the slow plodding footsteps
of his patients dragging their swollen
limbs across the ground blinking their
milky white eyes at the chaos outside of
the windows of the facility as 049 was
absorbed in his work the rest of the
escaped anomalies began to realize that
their freedom had come at a cost where
there had once been friendly yellow
sunlight beaming down on a lush green
world there was now an angry red fire in
the sky and a landscape covered in
strange gelatinous masses roving and
oozing and moaning as one they had
escaped from their cells but they were
still trapped their prison had just
gotten larger the doctor had not yet
noticed this unfortunate truth so focus
was he on treating the patients they had
recovered from the morgue at least the
ones that had not been given to
ferdinand to satisfy his mammoth
appetite however a week later the doctor
was horrified to discover that there
were no more corpses left no more
patience to cure he stood in the empty
morgue looking from drawer to drawer for
just one body they had missed proof that
his work was not over so soon what's the
matter doctor a sardonic voice behind
him said he turned to find
scp-035 attached to the face of a
mannequin i see you procured the body he
noted no thanks to you the mask replied
oh how sad a doctor with no one to treat
what will you do now that you have no
purpose in life i wonder there will be
more the doctor insisted there is an
entire world out there that needs my
help the mask laughed in disbelief
[Laughter]
you mean you haven't noticed there's no
word left to help it's all gone to hell
take a look for yourself the doctor
rushed to an upstairs window and gazed
down at the destruction outside the
painful red sunlight the rubble where
there were once buildings the masses of
soft gooey matter that aimlessly
squelched along the ground no he put a
hand to his beak shaking his head it
can't be but it is said the mask
standing behind him its face was locked
in a grin delighted to see him suffering
so your life's mission gone just like
that the doctor's knees went weak as he
tried to take it all in perhaps the mask
was right he had no purpose anymore but
then ferdinand's voice boomed from below
doctor we need your assistance
downstairs quickly the doctor followed
his assistant's cries and saw what was
so urgent one of the blob creatures an
entity he knew must have once been a
human being had found its way inside the
facility ferdinand stood back from it
afraid to touch its slimy surface but
scp-049 did not see a monster there
oozing across the floor he saw someone
who was sick desperately ill and in need
of help in need of a doctor do not be
afraid my friend he sat down his bag and
reached inside as his reanimated helper
swarmed around the blob creature you are
not well but i'm going to help you the
great dying may have been out of his
grasp but if the scene outside the
window was anything to go on there was
still a plague raging across the earth
and he was going to find the cure don't
forget go to scp-swag.com to order a
plague dr plush of your very own that's
scpswag.com
then go check out scp-049 the plague
doctor and when day breaks
scp-096 for more on the plague doctor
and what happened to another scp after
day finally broke